[Music]
we're already
on to the second quantum revolution
enlighten us what kind of oddities or
weirdnesses can we expect here
now the the second quantum revolution
exploits the really the the properties
that are exemplified by the schoniger
cat
and so they exploit the fact that
we can put a system into a superposition
of state
they exploit also another important
ingredient
of quantum mechanics is that it is
the the law of quantum mechanics do not
obey
the law of uh classical
logic so if you think again
of the curtain of what it means a
superposition of state
you we have at the quantum level that
the system can be in a superposition of
state that correspond to
different discrete outcomes and as we
we said you will obtain a definite
outcome that correspond to one of the
states at the moment
where you make a measurement but before
you make the measurement
the outcome is non-defined it's
completely non-defined and
this very fact is in contradiction with
classical logic because since the time
of aristotle
another greek philosopher from the 4th
century bc classical logic relies
on the identity principle and the
identity principle is
what you already alluded to when we were
talking about the cut
is that a logic proposition cannot be at
the same time
true and false and
as you said an apple is not an orange
and we can also say
a cat is not a dog right but
in quantum mechanics we can be in a
superposition
of outcome that are technically called
mutually exclusive this is really what
it is about
when we invoke the identity principle to
be
dead or alive are two mutually exclusive
propositions and so we can
exploit this fact that we can bring a
system into a superposition of state
to design new way of computing
that are different from the classical
computing
approach where in classical computing we
encode
the information into a classical bit
which is a physical system that can be
that can take two different values
a classical bit can be in
a state that correspond to a logical one
or
in a state that corresponds to a logical
zero but it cannot be
both at the same time but now think of
the cat
or of a quantum system that can be
in a superposition at the same time of
two states that have the outcome that
correspond to zero or one
this will allow me to process
these two output in a parallel way
and this parallelism is really the
essence
that is exploited in the second quantum
revolution because if i think of
computing
i have a qubit and then i can build
several queue bits
and the fact that i can process all the
inputs in parallel
instead of having to process them one
after the other
or separately like in a classical
computer
lead to an exponentially
faster way to process information
or to carry out complex computational
tasks and this is really the
prospect that is becoming available
by developing quantum computers quantum
computers
will allow us to to
carry out a computational task
in a time that is exponentially shorter
than
the time that is needed by a classical
computer and this opens
a lot of new avenues in
very many different areas in in logistic
in all the domain where you need
to process a lot of information right in
a short time think for example of
application to health right you have
lots of data but you want to react
quickly we have a good example now with
the pandemi
you can couple this very fast processing
of information with artificial
intelligence and then it is very
important
also for a lot of applications for
logistics
or you can do what fine mind was
proposing
to simulate complex quantum system
with a quantum computer and this also
opened a lot of new avenues
you